- In many parts of the world,
Scrabble is viewed as a pastime,
as a game where, maybe old people play
after retirement and all that,
but Scrabble in Nigeria
is actually very big.
It is seen as a sport.
There is an actual Nigerian
Scrabble Federation
under the Ministry of Sports.
They have a lot of young people
hoping to earn an actual
living from playing Scrabble.
My name is Wellington Jighere
and I'm the world Scrabble champion.
I started playing Scrabble in 1996
when my immediate elder
brother taught me the game.
It wasn't until six years after that,
I was playing with some
of my neighborhood friends
and they were like,
"Ah, you are quite good.
"Why not play in tournaments?"
And I was like,
"Wow, you mean they play
this in tournaments?"
The rest is history, as they say.
Having an African win the
World Scrabble Championship
is bigger than I can actual comprehend.
You needed to have been in the hall
to see the jubilation of
our other African brothers.
It was something that everyone in Africa
that plays Scrabble has
actually looked forward to.
Nigeria is a very, very diverse nation.
We have well over 500 developed languages,
but the major means of communication
all over Nigeria is English,
and since Scrabble is based
upon the English vocabulary,
it's going to be a way of
helping each and everyone
improve their command
of the English language.
If I hadn't played Scrabble,
I might have been involved in
some of the not so legitimate activities,
and I think playing Scrabble,
it keeps you on the right track.
We are not blind to the fact
that the level of unemployment
in the country is very, very immense,
so I came up with the
Wellington Foundation
for Scrabble and Mind
Development in Africa.
There's a lot of similarities between
how life actually goes
and how Scrabble goes.
You get to understand that it's not
all the time that you get things your way.
You really have to make the best
out of the little that you are given.
You know, each country is
known for a particular sport.
Brazil, for example,
is known for football.
We're hoping to make
Scrabble a Nigerian sport.
If you mention Scrabble
in any part of the world,
Nigeria should come to mind.